o la exigía el convoy humanitario hacia
jarquín la segunda ciudad más importante
del país y donde la artillería rusa
dispara a diario
este voluntario ucraniano sabe qué
significa trabajar bajo el sonido de los
proyectiles fue uno de los primeros en
evacuar a civiles de la ciudad asediada
de cerca de kiev
muchos eran mujeres y niños los llevé
cerca del puente cerca ir pin
son dos horas de viaje en las que hay
que pasar por varios checkpoint donde la
ayuda humanitaria se mezcla con
vehículos militares en kharkiv nos
espera se reactive el oncólogo de
radiología jefe del servicio del
hospital este centro es el único que hay
para tratar a todos los enfermos de
cáncer de la región
por desgracia el único dispensario
regional para oncología está dañado y
todos los médicos que trabajan allí lo
dejaron incluso ahora en este centro hay
combates activos y los proyectiles
llegan a esta zona por las consecuencias
de la invasión rusa en ucrania se
reflejan en los hospitales víctor está
el esquí es el director del centro de
salud tienen 100 pacientes de los cuales
sólo 50 pueden recibir radioterapia al
día porque es el máximo que puede
trabajar el aparato necesitan equipos de
tratamiento para poder cuál primo es por
supuesto por ciento esta máquina puede
ayudar a muchas personas ahora es la
única de este tipo que hay en el sureste
de ucrania
necesitamos muchísimo un acelerador
lineal como por hoy en bull
sobreviviendo
alexei tiene 72 años empezó su
tratamiento en plena
es difícil estar enfermo con la guerra
es muy difícil con los medicamentos nos
ayudan desde el oeste de ucrania podemos
hacer pedidos al oeste
markoff es una de las ciudades más
atacadas y bombardeadas desde el inicio
de la invasión rusa como este edificio
de la universidad de la administración
regional todos los días calla artillería
aquí casi todos los días hay heridos y
fallecidos pero los recursos son
limitados y los trabajadores de la salud
que quedan en esta ciudad resisten tan
solo 24 horas después de grabar este
reportaje un hospital muy cercano fue
bombardeado un jarquín otro más en esta
guerra donde los sanitarios luchan por
tratar a sus pacientes